do
fallout 4 is a dense and engrossing RPG
set in a post nuclear apocalypse version
of Boston once known for its historical
significance and modern academic
prestige Boston is now defined by ruined
buildings and vile mutants death and
desperation surround you yet you can't
look away it's hard to resist the allure
of unravelling mysteries and discovering
forgotten sanctuaries as you dig deeper
into myriad enclaves that called a
wasteland home go where you wish deal
with people in problems however you want
but be sure to watch your back it's not
unusual to find yourself hunted by
oafish mutants while you struggle with
wounded limbs radiation poisoning or an
unfortunate lack of ammo you could take
shelter in a dilapidated train station
but it's not worth the risk
scavengers may be lying in wait instead
you inject yourself with drugs lots of
them to get back on your feet with your
heightened perception and strength
giving you the edge you need to cut down
your pursuers with your final precious
bullets the heavy dusts of stimulus will
leave you addled but at least you can
survive to fight in search for traces of
your family another day it's wonderfully
tense moments like this that make
fallout for such an engaging and
intoxicating experience when fallout 4
shows its wrinkles it feels like a
direct extension of fallout 3 rather
than a sequel years in the making in so
many ways it shows a lack of progress
however the more time you spend with the
game the less you care when you're
enraptured with characters struggling
with difficult decisions and engaged in
combat you no longer care that something
could look better or be more organized
you may examine the game closely and
recognize flaws but when you put the
controller down you think about the
friend you betrayed the shifting tide of
an incredible battle or the moment you
opened a drawer and found someone's
discarded effects making you wonder how
they felt before the bombs fell
combat is comprised of melee attacks and
gunplay with a massive number of weapon
variations to experiment with you can
hit a bloody homerun with an enemy's
head in a spiked bat or wield a sniper
rifle and pick off jerks from afar both
methods work opening up a vast range of
combat scenarios to explore in the
middle you can even modify your weapons
and other equipment by salvaging
everyday objects scattered throughout
Boston allowing you to tweak your
arsenal and extend its usefulness in
significant ways at any moment you have
the option to switch between third or
first-person perspective on the fly but
more importantly you can choose to fight
in real time or within an RPG rooted
command system you grow very familiar
with vats the system you can use to plot
every pull of the trigger it's an
extension of the same mechanic from
fallout 3 and Fallout New Vegas but
activating vats in those games pause the
action completely now it merely slows
down time and you're vulnerable when
picking your target as a result the
advantage to using vats versus fighting
in real time is that it gives you the
ability to aim for specific body parts
and consider how likely you are to hit
your mark and how much damage you will
inflict if you do the mix of utility and
strategy that it presents is encouraging
and it's a far more enjoyable and
effective tool than real time shooting
which is functional but lacking the
finesse found and dedicated shooting
games
FASS also frames your actions with
cinematic flair on occasion showcasing
the brutality of combat was tiring
while Boston steams beyond salvation you
can influence the lives of some locals
by constructing sanctuaries for them to
live in scrap junk that you find
throughout the city and you can erect
shelters establish small vegetable
gardens and fortify defense systems
there is a lot you can build and the
process is easy but unless you love to
be creative you may not find this
pursuit all that interesting beyond a
few side quests the game hardly
motivates you to partake in construction
there's something to be said for the
contrast between killing monsters and
providing aid to those in need but the
rewards really extend beyond gratitude
and some experience points with the
dense city to explore and greater
rewards to reap it's all too easy to
ignore this feature altogether from
farmland to financial districts and
throughout the depths of dangerous
ghettos like opportunities to profit
explore and form relationships though
you can choose to befriend betray or
belittle people you interact with the
two-word summations don't always do a
good job of forecasting the extent of
your eventual dialogue I was often
surprised by my character's tone and
choice of words fallout 4 is an
involving RPG with a wealth of stories
to explore and activities to engage in
but it's also an old-looking game you
immediately noticed poor character
models muddy textures and a bevy of
glitches poor organization and
accessibility makes managing your
inventory and navigating the world map
feel arduous the companions that you can
bring into battle are more trouble than
they're worth they often lose their way
and are difficult to control and you
need them to perform a certain task
in fact you feel lucky when they appear
next to you in battle because you grow
so accustomed to them getting stuck in a
stairwell or between two rocks with
Boston at your mercy you'll ultimately
have the power to push it over the edge
or rescue it from ruin but this isn't a
matter of good versus evil
you need to make difficult decisions
that force you to question your morals
and what it means to be human after the
final act of the main story you're left
to continue your adventure and though
some quests seem trite in the face of
the story's main conclusion they still
take you to fascinating places and
reward your curiosity fallout 4 is a
strong argument for substance over style
and it's a remarkable open-world RPG
you